le procès papon avec un témoin
prestigieux aujourd'hui à la barre
puisqu'il s'agissait de l'ancien premier
ministre pierre messmer cité par la
défense c'est-à-dire par l'avocate de
maurice papon
il a pourtant refusé de le soutenir il
affirme aussi qu'il ne veut pas que la
france soit rendu responsable des crimes
de vichy albert ripamonti pierre dick
gaullistes historiques témoigne ministre
des armées du général premier ministre
de georges pompidou
pierre messmer a côtoyé maurice papon à
partir de 1958 quand celui ci était
préfet de police de paris
homme de devoir pierre messmer est
convoqué il vient feu survenu unis
accusent le défendre je suis cité à
témoigner sous le serment et je n'ai pas
l'habitude quand je suis cité de me
retrouver à la barre ce héros de la
france libre ne se dérobe pas sans
indulgence pour vichy ce pouvoir
illégitime sévère avec la préfectorale
d'alors beaucoup de ses membres dit il
aurait dû démissionner dans le box
maurice papon à l'air nerveux et m e
varaut intervient un jury d'honneur a
reconnu sa qualité de résistants le
témoin hésite il est très difficile de
répondre m varrault insiste en pure
perte
le compagnon du général de gaulle n'est
pas venu pour soutenir l'ancien préfet
seul réconfort à propos de la répression
d'octobre 61
pierre messmer au nom du gouvernement de
l'époque a subi et alors qu'on ne s'y
attendait pas pierre messmer va laisser
éclater son courroux contre ce qu'ils
appellent les plus hautes autorités de
l'état
imputée à la france et aux français la
responsabilité des crimes de vichy est
intolérable et il se répète
le gaulliste de la première heure viser
d'abord jacques chirac et sa déclaration
au vel d'hiv
juillet 95 et là nous n'étions plus dans
le procès papon et dans celui de notre
histoire